alors que le monde est au prise avec une
crise de l'inflation jamais vu en 40 ans
en Suisse l'inflation n'a jamais dépassé
trois et demi pour cent ce sommet a été
atteint l'été dernier comment expliquer
l'exception Suisse on retrouve ce soir
John Plassard spécialiste en
investissement chez Mirabeau à Genève en
Suisse bonsoir Monsieur placard
bonsoir merci de me recevoir alors que
la planète a connu et connaît d'ailleurs
toujours une crise inflationniste
qu'est-ce qui fait que la Suisse s'en
sort à si bon compte en ce moment
bah écoutez il y a plusieurs d'abord il
faut rappeler une chose c'est que à 3,4%
en janvier on est à des standards qui
sont au-dessus de nos moyennes
historiques en Suisse qui était plutôt
en dessous de 2%, ça c'est la première
définition et après il y a je crois
qu'il y a trois raisons qui expliquent
pourquoi le taux de d'inflation est si
bas la première chose c'est la vigueur
du franc suisse c'est que le franc
suisse une devise refuse et en fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est que on est
dans une situation où on ayant une franc
suisse qui est fort et bien les produits
importés sont moins chers il faut
rappeler que l'année passée par exemple
on a importé plus de 300 milliards de
dollars ensuite la deuxième des choses
c'est qu'on a un mix énergétique qui est
différent vous savez on consomme on l'a
beaucoup de lacs c'est de montagne et on
a on consomme notamment 14% de notre
énergie hydraulique on importe comment
on est moins dépendants de la
rue 3e c'est que aussi on a la majeure
partie des entreprises dans l'énergie
qui sont étatisés c'est l'État qui a la
main mise sur ses entreprises donc elle
arrive mieux à réguler le prix et puis
la troisième et la dernière raison
pourquoi l'inflation est si basse et
bien c'est le fait que la Suisse à la
base a déjà une base qui est très chère
si vous regardez les 10 villes les plus
chères du monde et bien vous trouvez
dans ces 10 villes Genève et Zurich qui
sont deux villes suisses et donc ce
qu'on appelle
l'îlot de sherté puisque on a toujours
été habitué à une certaine
à des prix qui sont plus chers que
d'habitude et donc c'est pour ça aussi
c'est ce qui explique pourquoi et bien
l'inflation est si basse alors c'est un
pays cher c'est un pays riche la Suisse
est l'un des pays les plus riches du
monde le salaire moyen de 68000 francs
suisses 100000 dollars canadiens donc
richesse est donc un facteur également
pour expliquer la limitation en quelque
sorte de l'inflation
oui tout à fait et puis ce qu'on voit
aussi ce qui est très important dans le
calcul de l'inflation en Suisse c'est
que on voit que les biens non essentiels
pèsent très peu qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que en fait
l'inflation est ce qu'on pourrait moins
acheter puisque l'inflation est plus
forte et bien c'est plutôt tout ce qui
est de l'ordre des services de l'ordre
des voyages de l'ordre des hôtels donc
en fait ce qu'on remarque c'est quand
l'inflation est trop élevée et bien les
Suisses ils partent un petit peu moins
en vacances oui dépensent un tout petit
peu moins pour leur voyage mais ce qu'il
faut rappeler aussi dans le chiffre que
vous avez dit avant sur un salaire moyen
qui est très élevé c'est que les charges
aussi sont très élevées quel est le rôle
de la Banque nationale suisse parce que
contrairement à l'Europe qui a sa banque
centrale maintenant
centralisé en quelque sorte bien que
certaines banques centrales ont certains
endroits en Europe ensuite il y a la
Banque nationale suisse le fait d'avoir
une banque centrale ind épendante ça
change des choses
oui ça change beaucoup de choses parce
que en fait la Banque nationale suisse a
aussi ce rôle totalement officiel de
réguler la valeur du franc suisse
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que la Banque nationale suisse a pris il
y a pas très longtemps le choix d'avoir
un franc suisse qui soit plus fort parce
qu'avant on essaie défendre un franc
suisse qui était un peu plus faible
parce que comme je disais avant si vous
avez un franc suisse qui est fort et
bien les produits importés et bien sont
plutôt déflationnistes qu'inflationniste
donc on voit que l'importance de la
Banque Nationale à la Suisse sur la
vigueur du front et donc sur l'inflation
est très très importante chez nous
qu'est-ce que les autres pays du monde
ont à apprendre dans ce cas-là du modèle
économique suisse si on peut se
permettre
bah écoutez une des premières choses
alors c'est différent au Canada parce
que vous êtes producteur d'énergie mais
je dirais que pour les autres pays d'une
certaine manière et c'est difficile de
dire ça parce qu'on est un pays plutôt
capitaliste en Suisse c'est qu'il faut
nationaliser en partie ou totalement les
secteurs qui sont cruciaux comme le
secteur de l'énergie et on voit que en
ayant nationalisé certaines entreprises
et bien on a réussi à réguler et bien la
hausse du prix de l'énergie en 2022 et
d'autres facteurs également qu'on
devrait suivre de la Suisse
bah écoutez c'est aussi l'aspect
culturel vous savez ce que je dis
souvent c'est que on est un des seuls
pays où on n'a pas eu d'aide pour les
prix à la pompe les prix à l'essence qui
ont été les plus importants en Europe et
on n'a pas une manifestation parce que
on dit comme je disais avant qu'on est
un îlot de fierté qu'on comprend d'une
certaine manière que c'est une phase qui
peut durer un certain moment mais qui ne
durera pas parce que on a totalement
confiance dans le gouvernement et aussi
dans la Banque nationale suisse bien
très intéressant je suis content qu'on
ait fait cet entretien pour mieux
comprendre la situation de l'inflation
John Plassard à Genève merci
merci beaucoup très bonne journée pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI